this guy you're punching the nose huh
yeah no he's trying to breathe better
oh you guys are all about the nose nasal
strips yeah the nasal
or do i know about it no i know you know
about it i need it please yeah i do it
we both you talk about nasal strips like
i talked about jared this is the second
time i talk about nasal strip on this
[ __ ] show man i don't think so you
did a whole pod that's when the show's
getting this right there that even that
photo oh she does look good
she does she does say he looks like the
artist
no no no he was just doing one of his
theater things
which we liked
that's a great call yeah it's good mark
ryden i'll never forget that yep
okay
yo what obtained this thing what's up
chan who uh i know you're going to say
ones that show up every day
consistently uh steven from sat down
yeah we got a king of distinctions fair
that's fair breathe right strips out in
public
i saw that uh episode you guys did the
other day where um no chris and theo
were talking about how great they were
so i tried them last night for the first
time and i just didn't take it off
awesome
so uh i'm cool with walking around
outside right now with my douchebag
because i can breathe like [ __ ] zeus
if any girls out there are digging this
uh breathe right drip
that uh clean passageway that oxygen
rich
drip
pick me up i love this country all right
there's so many there's so many things
that you can say about this so first of
all
yes sleeping with a breathe right strip
is great okay because you don't want to
sleep with your mouth [ __ ] open for
two reasons you wake up with a sore
throat or spiders crawl in your mouth
okay or you have a mouth like a parrot
because your mouth is real dry which i
deal with every night right which sucks
so you use the breathing mouth
so you use a breathe right strip so you
can sleep with your mouth closed i get
it in daytime when you wake up yeah you
can breathe through your [ __ ] mouth
okay you can do that so just do that
number two
if it still feels good after you wake up
you need surgery on your nose yeah you
need to get that fixed well why can't he
just go out and rock that like he's
tricking
defensive tackle in the 90s because of
the way it looks
it doesn't look good you're supposed to
just have your face on outside that's it
right you're not supposed to also have
other things on your face i think it's
pretty lit no yeah i like seeing asians
take advantage of
technology
i like seeing uh what can happen when
people try something different me too
fan of that not the first one this guy
seems like a champion to me but also i
think it takes balls to rock that out to
wear it all day it doesn't take balls
you're just worried about your inhaling
it doesn't take balls
no
bad nose the guy's got a bad nose he
needs to fix it small passageways bro i
have the worst nose in here much better
like that right how much better is that
dude will you walk behind me and just
pull my [ __ ] face like that
all day that would be amazing i'll smell
a fart from a mile away like this what
you can also just breathe if you want no
i can't breathe i don't know which one i
had no surgery
[Music]
and the sting and the wings